Let's imagine we run a retailer with thousands of stores around
the world. And we have a big ledger that contains all
of our sales, the big book of sales for the year
2012. We've been asked to calculate things like the total sales per
store for the year. Let's say the lines of the ledger
look like this. The date of the purchase, the location of the
store, what they bought, and the amount. One way we could
do this is just start at the beginning of the ledger and
for every entry we see, write down the store
location and the amount. Then keep going. For the fourth
entry, we see that we've already written down Miami. So
we'll update the amount to 62.15, and we would continue.